a cold case dating back nearly a half
century appears to have been cracked
this week investigators in pennsylvania
arrested david sinopoli in the 1975
murder of 19-year-old lindy sue beekler
bradley blackburn is here to explain how
police were able to track down synopoly
across the decades good morning bradley
dana good morning it was dna evidence
used to crack so many unsolved cases
investigators say they matched sanopolis
biological thumbprint back to that 1975
crime scene but how they use that dna to
find him might surprise you
this has been a
long and difficult case for everybody 46
and a half years police in lancaster
county pennsylvania relieved after
sunday's arrest of david sinopoli he's
now charged in the stabbing death of
lindy sue beekler this case has been
very emotional for many of our officers
they've shed tears they've had sleepless
nights
hoping one day an arrest would be made
and finally yesterday was made the
gruesome crime gripped this community
for nearly 50 years beekler a flower
shop employee was stabbed 19 times in
the living room of her apartment the
killer left behind the knife and his dna
this case was solved with the use of dna
and specifically dna genealogy and quite
honestly without that i don't know that
we would have ever solved it the case
began to crack in 2019 when
investigators extracted dna evidence
from biegler's underwear a dna research
firm used that information to come up
with these composite sketches of what
the suspect might have looked like in
1975
and the present day
researchers also determined the suspect
had ancestral ties to a small town in
southern italy that narrowed down the
number of potential suspects living in
lancaster county in 1975 to about 2300
from there they used court records
newspaper archives and even social media
to zero in on sinopoli as a prime
suspect
the break came in february investigators
tracked sanopoli to philadelphia
international airport they recovered a
sample of his dna from a coffee cup they
watched him throw away police say it was
a match this is why we do what we do and
it's very meaningful for us
to be able to
try to provide some sense of relief to
the victims police say sonopoly was
never on their radar but he did live in
the same apartment complex as beekler at
the time of her murder and he spent the
past 30 years living less than five
miles from the crime scene
and sanopley is being held without bail
investigators say the dna match is one
in 10 trillion and for weeks leading up
to her murder guys lindy sue biekler
told her husband and other relatives
that she thought someone had been
watching her it's so amazing that he
lived in her building and wasn't even
looked at i know it just seems so
bizarre like with just a handful of
people who lived in the same building
with her absolutely and that is one
powerful cup of coffee too
yes bradley thank you very much